quel message avez vous pour tous ceux
qui viennent soutenir julien assange
ah oui film savez vous ce qu'il pense
des manifestants qui viennent à la
prison pour le soutenir
il est ravi d'ailleurs de daiwa
l'autre jour quand il y avait des
français devant la prison il faisait
beaucoup de bruit
julian m'a dit qu'il pouvait entendre
les manifestants depuis sa cellule
c'est très encourageant la prison vous
enlève votre indépendance et votre
humanité
cette humanité vous revient quand vous
vous rendez compte que les gens à
l'extérieur de la prison vous aime et
vous soutiennent ouais je pense qu'en
france où dit cher pour les français